The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to spend
most of time talking about
chapters one, two, and three.
A little bit talking about
chapter four, because we've
been doing so much with chapter
four in the last
couple of weeks that you
probably remember that more.
OK.
The basics, which we started out
with, and which you should
never forget, is that any time
you develop a probability
model, you've got to specify
what the sample space is and
what the probability measure
on that sample space is.
And in practice, and in almost
everything we've talked about
so far, there's really a basic
countable set of random
variables which determine
everything else.
In other words, when you find
the joint probability
distribution on that set of
random variables, that tells
you everything else
of interest.
And a sample point or a sample
path on that set of random
variables is in a collection of
sample values, one sample
value for each random
variable.
It's very convenient, especially
when you're in an
exam and a little bit rushed,
to confuse random variables
with the sample values for
the random variables.
And that's fine.
I just want to caution you
again, and I've done this many
times, that about half the
mistakes that people make--
half of the conceptual mistakes
that people make
doing problems and doing quizzes
are connected with
getting confused at some point
about what's a random variable
and what's a sample value
of that random variable.
And you start thinking about
sample values as just numbers.
And I do that too.
It's convenient for thinking
about things.
But you have to know that that's
not the whole story.
Often, we have uncountable
sets of random variables.
Like in renewal processes, we
have the counting renewal
process, which typically has an
uncountable set of random
variables, a number of arrivals
up to each time, t,
where t is a continuous valued
random variable.
But in almost all of those
cases, you can define things
in terms of simpler sets of
random variables, like the
interarrival times,
which are IID.
Most of the processes we've
talked about really have a
pretty simple description if
you look for the simplest
description of them.
If you have a sequence of
IID random variables--
which is what we have for
Poisson and renewal processes,
and what we have for Markov
chains is not that much more
complicated--
the laws of large numbers are
useful to specify what the
long term behavior is.
The sample time average is, as
we all know by now, is the sum
of the random variables
divided by n.
So it's a sample average
of these quantities.
The random variable, which has
a main x bar, the expected
value of x, that's
almost obvious.
You just take the expected value
of s sub n, and it's n
times the expected value of x
divided by n, and you're done.
And the variance, since these
random variables are
independent, you find that
almost as easily.
That has this very
simple-minded
distribution function.
Remember, we usually work
with distribution
functions in this class.
And often, the exercises are
much easier when you do them
in terms of the distribution
function than if you use
formulas you remember from
elementary courses, which are
specialized to--
which are specialized to
probability density and
probability mass functions, and
often have more special
conditions on them than that.
But anyway, the distribution
function starts
to look like this.
As n gets bigger, you notice
that what's happening is that
you get a distribution which
is scrunching in this way,
which is starting to
look smoother.
The jumps in it gets smaller.
And you start out with this
thing which is kind of crazy.
And by time, n is even 50.
You get something which
almost looks like a--
I don't know how we tell
the difference
between those two things.
I thought we could,
but we can't.
I certainly can't up there.
But anyway, the one that's
tightest in is the one
for n equals 50.
And what these laws of large
numbers all say in some sense
is that this distribution
function gets crunched in
towards an impulse
at the mean.
And then they say other more
specialized things about how
this happens, about sample
paths and all of that.
But the idea is that this
distribution function is
heading towards a
unit impulse.
The weak law of large numbers
then says that if the expected
value of the magnitude of x
is less than infinity--
and usually when we talk about
random variables having a
mean, that's exactly
what we mean.
If that condition is not
satisfied, then we usually say
that the random variable
doesn't have a mean.
And you'll see that every time
you look at anything in
probability theory.
When people say the mean exists,
that's what they
always mean.
And what the theorem says then
is exactly what we were
talking about before.
The probability that the
difference between s n over n,
and the mean of x bar, the
probability that it's greater
than or equal to epsilon
equals 0 in the limit.
So it's saying that you put
epsilon limits on that
distribution function and let
n get bigger and bigger, it
goes to 1 and 0.
It says the probability of s n
over n, less than or equal to
x, approaches a unit step as
n approaches infinity.
This says this is the condition
for convergence in
probability.
What we're saying is that that
also means convergence and
distribution function, and
distribution for this case.
And then we also, when we got
to renewal processes, we
talked about the strong
law of large numbers.
And that says that the expected
value of x is finite.
Then this limit approaches
x on a sample path basis.
In other words, for every sample
path, except this set
of probability 0, this
condition holds true.
That doesn't seem like it's
very different or very
important for the time being.
But when we started studying
renewal processes, which is
where we actually talked about
this, we saw that in fact, it
let us talk about this, which
says that if you take any
function of s n over n--
in other words, a function
of a real value--
a function of a--
a real valued function of a--
a real valued function
of a real value, yes.
What you get is that
same function
applied to the mean here.
And that's the thing
which is so
useful for renewal processes.
And it's what usually makes
the strong law of large
numbers so much easier to
use than the weak law.
That's a plug for
the strong law.
There are many extensions of the
week love telling how fast
the convergence is.
One thing you should always
remember about the central
limit theorem, is it really
tells you something about the
weak law of large numbers.
It tells you how fast that
convergence is and what the
convergence looks like.
It says that if the variance
of this underlying random
variable is finite, then this
limit here is equal to the
normal distribution function,
the Gaussian at
variance 1 and mean 0.
And that becomes a little easier
to see what it's saying
if you look at it this way.
It says probability that s
n over n minus x bar--
namely the difference between
the sum and the mean which
it's converging to--
the probability that that's less
than or equal to y sigma
over square root of
n is this normal
Gaussian random variable.
It says that as n gets bigger
and bigger, this quantity here
gets tighter and tighter.
What it says in terms of the
picture here, in terms of this
picture, it says that as n gets
bigger and bigger, this
picture here scrunches down as
1 over the square root of n.
And it also becomes Gaussian.
| it tells you exactly what
kind of convergence you
actually have here.
Is not only saying that this
does converge to a unit step.
It says how it converges.
And that's a nice thing,
conceptually.
You don't always need
it in problems.
But you need it for
understanding what's going on.
We're moving backwards,
it seems.
Now, 1, 2, Poisson processes.
We talked about arrival
processes.
You'd almost think that all
processes are arrival
processes at this point.
But any time you start to think
about that, think of a
Markov chain.
And a Markov chain is not an
arrival process, ordinarily.
Some of them can be
viewed that way.
But most of them can't.
An arrival processes
is an increasing
sequence of random variables.
0 less than s1, which is the
time of the first arrival, s2,
which is a time of the second
arrival, and so forth.
Interarrival times are x1 equals
s1, and x i equals s i
minus s i minus 1.
The picture, which you should
have indelibly printed on the
back of your brain someplace
by this time, is
this picture here.
s1, s2, s3, are the times
at which arrivals occur.
These are random variables, so
these arrivals come in at
random times.
x1, x2, x3 are the intervals
between arrivals.
And N of t is the number of
arrivals that have occurred up
until time t.
So every time the t passes one
of these arrival times, N of t
pops up by one, pops up by one
again, pops up by one again.
The sample value
pops up by one.
Arrival process can model
arrivals to a queue,
departures from a queue,
locations of breaks in an oil
line, an enormous number
of things.
It's not just arrivals
we're talking about.
It's all of these other
things, also.
But it's something laid out on
a one-dimensional axis where
things happen at various
places on that
one-dimensional axis.
So that's the way to view it.
OK, same picture again.
Process can be specified by the
joint distribution of the
arrival epochs or the
interarrival times, and, in
fact, of the counting process.
If you see a sample path of
the counting process, then
from that you can determine the
sample path of the arrival
times and the sample path of
the interarrival times.
And since any set of these
random variables specifies all
three of these things, the
three are all equivalent.
OK, we have this important
condition here.
And I always sort of forget
this, but when these arrivals
are highly delayed, when there's
a long period of time
between each arrival, what that
says is the accounting
process is getting small.
So big interarrival times
corresponds to a small
value of N of t.
And you can see that in
the picture here.
If you spread out these
arrivals, you make s1 all the
way out here.
Then N of t doesn't become
1 until way out here.
So N of t as a function of t is
getting smaller as s sub n
is getting larger.
S sub n is the minimum of the
set of t, such that N of t is
greater than or equal to N.
Sounds like a unpleasantly
complicated expression.
If any of you can find a simpler
way to say it than
that, I would be absolutely
delighted to hear it.
But I don't think there is.
I think the simpler way to say
it is this picture here.
And the picture says it.
And you can sort of figure out
all those logical statements
from the picture, which
is intuitively a
lot clearer, I think.
So now, renewal processes is
an arrival process with IID
interarrival times.
And a Poisson process is a
renewal process where the
interarrival random variables
are exponential.
So, Poisson process
is a special
case of renewal process.
Why are these exponential
interarrival
arrival times so important?
Well, it's because they're
memoryless.
And the memoryless property says
that the probability that
x is greater than t plus x is
equal to the probability that
it's greater than x times the
probability that it's greater
than t for all x and t greater
than or equal to 0.
This makes better sense if
you say it conditionally.
The probability that x is
greater than t plus x, given
that it's greater than t, is
the same as the probability
that x is greater that--
capital X is greater
than little x.
This really gives you
the memoryless
property in a nutshell.
It says if you're looking at
this process as it evolves,
and you see an arrival, and then
you start looking for the
next arrival, it says that no
matter how long you've been
looking, the distribution
function, as the time to wait
until the next arrival,
is the same
exponential random variable.
So you never gain anything
by waiting.
You might as well
be impatient.
But it doesn't do any good
to be impatient.
Doesn't to any good to wait.
It doesn't do any good
to not wait.
No matter what you do, this
damn thing always takes an
exponential amount
of time to occur.
OK, that's what it means
to be memoryless.
And the exponential is the only
memoryless random variable.
How about a geometric
random variable?
The geometric random variable
is memoryless if you're only
looking at integer times.
Here we're talking about
times on a continuum.
That's what this says.
Well, that's what this says.
And if you look at discrete
times, then a geometric random
variable is memoryless also.
We're given a Poisson
of rate lambda.
The interval from any given t
greater than 0 until the first
arrival after t is a
random variable.
Let's call it z1.
We already said that that
random variable was
exponential.
And it's independent of all
arrivals which occur before
that starting time t.
So looking at any starting
time t, doesn't make any
difference what has happened
back here.
That's not only the
last arrival, but
all the other arrivals.
The time until the next arrival
is exponential.
The time until each arrival
after that is exponential
also, which says that if you
look at this process starting
at time t, it's a Poisson
process again, where all the
times have to be shifted, of
course, but it's a Poisson
process starting at time t.
The corresponding counting
process, we can call it n
tilde of t and tau, where tau is
greater than or equal to t,
where this is the number of
arrivals in the original
process up until time tau minus
the number of arrivals
up until time t.
If you look at that difference,
so many arrivals
up until t, so many more
up until time tau.
You look at the difference
between tau and t.
The number of arrivals in that
interval is the same Poisson
distributing random
variable again.
So, it has the same
distribution as N
of tau minus t.
And that's called the stationary
increment property.
It says that no matter where you
start a Poisson process,
it always looks exactly
the same.
It says that if you wait for one
hour and start then, it's
exactly the same as what
it was before.
If we had Poisson processes in
the world, it wouldn't do any
good to travel on certain days
rather than other days.
It wouldn't do any good to leave
to drive home at one
hour rather than another hour.
You'd have the same travel
all the time.
It's all equal.
It would be an awful world
if it were stationary.
The independent increment
properties for counting
process is that for all
sequences of ordered times--
0 less than t1 less than
t2 up to t k--
the random variables n of t1--
and now we're talking about the
number of arrivals between
t1 and t2, the number
of arrivals between
n minus 1 and tn.
These are all independent
of each other.
That's what this independent
increment property says.
And we see from what we've said
about this memoryless
property that the Poisson
process does indeed have this
independent increment
property.
Poisson processes have both the
stationary and independent
increment properties.
And this looks like an immediate
consequence of that.
It's not.
Remember, we had to struggle
with this for a bit.
But it says plus Poisson
processes can be defined by
the stationary and independent
increment properties, plus
either the Poisson PMF for N
of t, or this incremental
property, the probability that N
tilde of t and t plus delta,
and the number of arrivals
between t and t plus delta,
the probability that that's
1 is equal to
lambda times delta.
In other words, this view of a
Poisson process is the view
that you get when you sort
of forget about time.
And you think of arrivals from
outer space coming down and
hitting on a line.
And they hit on that
line randomly.
And each one of them
is independent
of every other one.
And that's what you get if you
wind up with a density of
lambda arrivals per unit time.
OK, we talked about all
of that, of course.
The probability distributions--
there are many of them for
a Poisson process.
The Poisson process is
remarkable in the sense that
anything you want to find,
there's generally a simple
formula for it.
If it's complicated, you're
probably not looking at
it the right way.
So many things come out
very, very simply.
The probability--
the joint probability
distribution of all of the
arrival times up until time N is
an exponential just in the
last one, which says that the
intermediate arrival epochs
are equally likely to be
anywhere, just as long as they
satisfy this ordering
restriction, s1 less than s2.
That's what this formula says.
It says that the joint density
of these arrival times doesn't
depend on anything except the
time of the last one.
But it does depend on the fact
that they're [INAUDIBLE].
From that, you can find
virtually everything else if
you want to.
That really is saying exactly
the same thing as we were just
saying a while ago.
This is the viewpoint of looking
at this line from
outer space with arrivals coming
in, coming in uniformly
distributed over this line
interval, and each of them
independent of each other one.
That's what you wind
up saying.
This density, then, of the
n-th arrival, if you just
integrate all this stuff, you
get the Erlang formula.
Probability of arrival n in
t to t plus delta is--
now this is the derivation that
we went through before,
going from Erlang to Poisson.
You can go from Poisson to
Erlang too, if you want to.
But it's a little easier
to go this way.
The probability of arrival in
t to t plus delta is the
probability that n of t is
equal to n minus 1 times
lambda delta plus an o
of delta, of course.
And the probability that n of
t is equal to n minus 1 from
this formula here is going to be
the density of when s sub n
appears, divided by lambda.
That's exactly what this
formula here says.
So that's just the Poisson
distribution.
We've been through
that derivation.
It's almost a derivation worth
remembering, because it just
appears so often.
As you've seen from the problem
sets we've done,
almost every problem you can
dream of, dealing with Poisson
processes, the easy way to do
them comes from this property
of combining and splitting
Poisson processes.
It says if n1 of t, n2 of t,
up to n sub k of t are
independent Poisson
processes--
what do you mean by
a process being
independent of another process?
Well, the process is specified
by the interarrival times for
that process.
So what we're saying here is the
interarrival times for the
first process are independent
of the interarrival times of
the second process,
independent of the
interarrival times for the third
process, and so forth.
Again, this is a view of someone
from outer space,
throwing darts onto a line.
And if you have multiple people
throwing darts on a
line, but they're all equally
distributed, all uniformly
distributed over the line,
this is exactly
the model you get.
So we have two views here.
The first one is to look at
the arrival epochs that's
generated from each process.
And then combine all arrivals
into one Poisson process.
So we look at all these Poisson
processes, and then
take the sum of them, and we
get a Poisson process.
The other way to look at it--
and going back and forth between
these two views is the
way you solve problems--
you look at the combined
sequence of
arrival epochs first.
And then for each arrival that
comes in, you think of an IID
random variable independent
of all the other random
variables, which decides for
each arrival which of the
sub-processes it goes to.
So there's this hidden
process--
well, it's not hidden.
You can see what it's doing
from looking at all the
sub-processes.
And each arrival then is
associated with the given
sub-process, with the
probability mass function
lambda sub i over the
sum of lambda sub j.
So this is the workhorse
of Poisson
type queueing problems.
You study queuing theory,
every page, you
see this thing used.
If you look at Kleinrock's books
on queueing, they're
very nice books because they
cover so many different
queueing situations.
You find him using this
on every page.
And he never tells you that he's
using it, but that's what
he's doing.
So that's a useful
thing to know.
We then talked about conditional
arrivals and order
statistics.
The conditional distribution
of the N first arrivals--
namely, s sub 1 s sub
2 up to s sub n--
given the number of arrivals in
N of t is just n factorial
over t to the n.
Again, it doesn't depend on
where these arrivals are.
It's just a function which is
independent of each arrival.
It's the same kind of
conditioning we had before.
It's n factorial divided
by t to the n.
Because of the fact that if
you order these random
variables, t1 less than t2 less
than t3, and so forth, up
until time t, and then you say
how many different ways can I
arrange a set of numbers, each
between 0 and t so that we
have different orderings
of them.
And you can choose any one
of the N to be the first.
You can choose any one
of the remaining n
minus 1 to be the second.
And that's where this is n
factorial comes from here.
And that, again we've
been over.
The probability that s1 is
greater than tau, given that
they're interarrivals in the
overall interval t, comes from
just looking at N uniformly
distributed random variables
between 0 and t.
And then what do you do with
those uniformly distributed
random variables?
Well, you ask the question,
what's the probability that
all of them occur
after time tau?
And that's just t minus tau
divided by t raised to the
n-th power.
And see, all of these formulas
just come from particular
viewpoints about what's
going on.
You have a number
of viewpoints.
One of them is throwing
darts at a line.
One of them is having
exponential
interarrival times.
One of them is these uniform
interarrivals.
It's only a very small
number of tricks.
And you just use them in
various combinations.
So the joint distribution of s1
to s n, given N of t equals
n, is the same as the joint
distribution of N uniform
random variables after
they've been ordered.
So let's go on to finite
state Markov chains.
Seems like we're covering an
enormous amount of material in
this course.
And I think we are.
But as I'm trying to say, as
we go along, it's all--
I mean, everything follows from
a relatively small set of
principles.
Of course, it's harder to
understand the small set of
principles and how to apply them
than it is to understand
all the details.
But that's--
but on the other hand, if you
understand the principles,
then all those details,
including the ones we haven't
talked about, are easy
to deal with.
An integer-time stochastic
process--
x1, x2, x3, blah, blah, blah--
is a Markov chain if for all n,
namely the number of them
that we're looking at--
well--
for all n, i, j, k, l, and so
forth, the probability that
the n-th of these random
variables is equal to j, given
what all of the others are-- and
these are not ordered now.
I mean, in a Markov chain,
nothing is ordered.
We're not talking about
an arrival process.
We're just talking about a frog
jumping around on lily
pads, if you arrange the lily
pads in a linear way, if these
are random variables.
The probability that the n-th
location is equal to j, given
that the previous locations are
i, k, back to m, is just
some probability p sub
i j, a conditional
probability of j given i.
In other words, once if you're
looking at what happens at
time n, once you know what
happened at time n minus 1,
everything else is
of no concern.
This process evolves by having
a history of only one time
unit, a little like the
Poisson process.
The Poisson process evolves
by being totally
independent of the past.
Here, you put a little
dependence in the past.
But the dependence is only to
look at the last thing that
happened, and nothing before the
last time that happened.
So p sub i j depends
only on i and j.
And the initial probability mass
function is arbitrary.
Markov chain is finite-state if
the sample space for each x
i, as a finite set S. And the
sample space S is usually
taken to be integers
1 up to M.
In all these formulas we write,
we're always summing
from one to M. And the reason
for that is we've assumed the
states are 1, 2, 3, up to M.
Sometimes it's more convenient
to think of different
state spaces.
But all the formulas
we use are based on
this state space here.
Markov up chain is completely
described by these transition
probabilities plus the initial
probabilities.
If you want to write down the
probability of what x is this
some time N given what was at
some time 0, all you have to
do is trace all the paths from
0 out to N, add up the
probabilities of all of those
paths, and that tells you the
probability you want.
All probabilities and be
calculated just from knowing
what these transition
probabilities are.
Note that when we're dealing
with Poisson processes, we
defined everything in
terms of how many--
how many variables are there in
defining a Poisson process?
How many things do you have to
specify before I know exactly
what Poisson process
I'm talking about?
Only the Poisson rate.
Only one parameter is necessary
for a Poisson process.
For a finite-state Markov
process, you need a lot more.
What you need is all of these
values, p sub i j.
If you sum p sub i j over
j, you have to get 1.
So that removes one of them.
But as soon as you specify that
transition matrix, you've
specified everything.
So there's nothing more to know
about the Poisson process.
There's only all these gruesome
derivations that we
go through.
But everything is initially
determined.
Set of transition probabilities
is usually
viewed as the Markov chain.
And the initial probabilities
are usually viewed as just a
parameter that we deal with.
In other words, we--
in other words, what we study
is the particular Markov
chain, whether it's recurrent,
whether it's transient,
whatever it is.
How you break it up into
classes, all of that stuff
only depends on these transition
probabilities and
doesn't depend on
where you start.
Now, a finite-state Markov chain
can be described either
as a directed graph
or as a matrix.
I hope you've seen by this
time that some things are
easier to look at if you look at
things in terms of a graph.
Some things are easier to look
at if you look at something
like this matrix.
And some problems can be solved
by inspection, if you
draw a graph of it.
Some can be solved almost
by inspection if
you look at the matrix.
If you're doing things by
computer, usually computers
deal with matrices more easily
than with graphs.
If you're dealing with a Markov
chain with 100,000
states, you're not going to
look at the graph and
determine very much from it,
because it's typically going
to be fairly complicated--
unless it has some very
simple structure.
And sometimes that simple
structure is determined.
If it's something where
you can only--
where you have the states
numbered from 1 to 100,000,
and you can only go from state
i to state i plus 1, or from
state i to i plus 1, or
i minus 1, then it
becomes very simple.
And you like to look at
it as a graph again.
But ordinarily, you don't
like to do that.
But the nice thing about this
graph is that it tells you
very simply and visually which
transition probabilities are
zero, and which transition
probabilities are non-zero.
And that's the thing that
specifies which states are
recurrent, which states are
transient, and all of that.
All of that kind of elementary
analysis about a Markov chain
all comes from looking at this
graph and seeing whether you
can get from one state to
another state by some process.
So let's move on from that.
Talk about the classification
of states.
We started out with the
idea of a walk and
a path and a cycle.
I'm not sure these terms are
uniform throughout the field.
But a walk is an ordered
string of nodes, like
i0, i1, up to i n.
You can have repeated elements
here, but you need a directed
arc from i sub n minus
1 to i sub m.
Like for example, in this stupid
Markov chain here--
I mean, when you're drawing
things is LaTeX, it's kind of
hard to draw those nice
little curves there.
And because of that, when you
once draw a Markov chain, you
never want to change it.
And that's why these nodes
have a very small set of
Markov chains in them.
It's just to save me some work,
drawing and drawing
these diagrams.
An example of a walk, as you
start in 4, you take the self
loop, go back to 4 at time 2.
Then you go to state
1 at time 3.
2 at time 4.
Then you go to stage
3, time 5.
And back to state 2 at time 6.
You have repeated nodes there.
You have repeated nodes
separated here.
Another example of a
walk is 4, 1, 2, 3.
Example of a path, the path
can't have any repeated nodes.
We'd like to look at paths,
because if you're going to be
able to get from one node to
another node, and there's some
walk that goes all around the
place and gets to that final
node, there's also path
that goes there.
If you look at the walk, you
just leave that all the cycles
along the way, and
you get to the n.
And a cycle, of course, which I
didn't define, is something
which starts at one node, goes
through a path, and then
finally comes back to the same
node that it started at.
And it doesn't make any
difference for the cycle 2, 3,
2 whether you call it
2, 3, 2 or 3, 2, 3.
That's the same cycle, and
it's not even worth
distinguishing between
those two ideas.
OK That's that.
If there's a path from--
where did I--
node j is accessible from i,
which we abbreviate as i
has a path to j.
If there's a walk from i to
j, which means that p
sup i j to the n--
this is the transition
probability, the probability
that x sub n is equal to
j, given that x sub
0 is equal to i.
And we use this all the time.
If this is greater than zero
for some n greater than 0.
In other words, j is accessible
from i if there's a
path from i that goes to j.
And trivially, if i go to j, and
there's a path from j to
k, then there has to be
a path from i to k.
If you've ever tried to make up
a mapping program to find
how to get from here to there,
this is one of the most useful
things you use.
If there's a way to get here
to there, and a way to get
from here to there, then there's
a way to get from here
all the way to the end.
And if you look up what most of
these map programs do, you
see that they overuse this
enormously and they wind up
taking you from here to there
by some bizarre path just
because it happens to go through
some intermediate node
on the way.
So two nodes communicate--
i double arrow j--
if j is accessible from i, and
if i is accessible from j.
That means there's a path from
i to j, and another path from
j back to i, if you shorten
them as much as you can.
There's a cycle.
It starts at i, goes through j,
and comes back to i again.
I didn't say that quite right,
so delete that from what
you've just heard.
A class C of states as a
non-empty set, such that i and
j communicate for each
i j in this class.
But i does not communicate
with j for each i and C--
for i and C and j, not in C.
The convenient way to think
about this-- and I should have
stated this as a theorem in
the notes, because it's--
I think it's something that
we all use without even
thinking about it.
It says that the entire set of
states, or the entire set of
nodes in a graph, is partitioned
into classes.
The class C, containing, is i
in union with all of the j's
that communicate with i.
So if you want to find this
partition, you start out with
an arbitrary node, you find all
of the other nodes that it
communicates with, and you
find them by picking
them one at a time.
You pick all of the nodes
for which p sub i j is
greater than 0.
Then you pick--
and p sub j i is great--
well-- blah.
If you want to find the set of
nodes that are accessible from
i, you start out looking at i.
You look at all the states
which are accessible
from i in one step.
Then you look at all the steps,
all of the states,
which you can access from
any one of those.
Those are the states which are
accessible in two states--
in two steps, then in three
steps, and so forth.
So you find all the nodes that
are accessible from node i.
And then you turn around and
do it the other way.
And presto, you have all of
these classes of states all
very simply.
For finite-state change, the
state i is transient if
there's a j in S such that
i goes into j, but j
does not go into i.
In other words, if I'm a state
i, and I can get to you, but
you can't get back to me,
then I'm transient.
Because the way Markov chains
work, we keep going from one
step to the next step to the
next step to the next step.
And if I keep returning to
myself, then eventually I'm
going to go to you.
And once I go to you, I'll
never get back again.
So because of that, these
transient states are states
where eventually you
leave them and you
never get back again.
As soon as we start talking
about countable state Markov
chains, you'll see that
this definition
doesn't work anymore.
You can--
it is very possible to just
wander away in a countable
state Markov chain, and you
never get back again that way.
After you wander away too far,
the probability of getting
back gets smaller and smaller.
You keep getting further
and further away.
The probability of returning
gets smaller and smaller, so
that you have transience
that way also.
But here, the situation is
simpler for a finite-state
Markov chain.
And you can define transience if
there's a j in S such that
i goes into j, but j
doesn't go into i.
If i's not transient,
then it's recurrent.
Usually you define recurrence
first and transience later,
but it's a little simpler
this way.
All states in a class are
transient, or all are
recurrent, and a finite-state
Markov chain contains at least
one recurrent class.
You did that in your homework.
And you were surprised at how
complicated it was to do it.
I hope that after you wrote
down a proof of this, you
stopped and thought about what
you were actually proving,
which intuitively is something
very, very simple.
It's just looking at all of
the transient classes.
Starting at one transient
class, you
find if there's another--
if there's another state you can
get to from OK i which is
also transient, and then you
find if there's another state
you get to from there which
is also transient.
And eventually, you have to come
to a state from which you
can't go to some other state,
from which you can't get back.
That was explaining it almost
as badly as the problem
statement explained it.
And I hope that after you did
the problem, even if you can't
explain it to someone,
you have an
understanding of why it's true.
It shouldn't be surprising
after you do that.
So the finite-state Markov chain
contains at least one
recurrent class.
OK, the period of a state
i as the greatest common
denominator of n, such that
p i n is greater than 0.
Again, a very complicated
definition for a
simple kind of idea.
Namely, you start out
in a state i.
You look at all of the times at
which you can get back to
state i again.
If you find it that set of
times has a period in it,
namely, if every sequences of
states is a multiple of some
d, then you know that the state
is periodic if d is
greater than 1.
And what you have to do is to
find the largest such number.
And that's the period
of the state.
All states in the same class
have the same period.
A recurring class with period
d greater than one can be
partitioned into sub-class--
this is the best way
of looking at
periodic classes of states.
If you have a periodic class of
states, then you can always
separate it into
d sub-classes.
And in such a set of
sub-classes, transitions from
S1 and the states in
S1 only go to S2.
Transitions from states
in S2 only go to S3.
Up to, transitions from S
d only go back to S1.
They have to go someplace,
so they go back to S1.
So as you cycle around, it takes
d steps to cycle from 1
back to 1 again.
It takes d steps to cycle
from 2 back to 2 again.
So you can see the structure of
the Markov chain and why,
in fact, it does have to be--
why that class has
to be periodic.
An ergodic class is a recurrent
aperiodic class.
In other words, it's a class
where the period is equal to
1, which means there really
isn't any period.
A Markov chain with only one
class is ergodic if the class
is ergodic.
And the big theorem here--
I mean, this is probably the
most important theorem about
finite-state Markov chains.
You have an ergodic,
finite-state Markov chain.
Then the limit as n goes to
infinity of the probability of
arriving in state j after n
steps, given that you started
in state i, is just some
function of j.
In other words, when n gets very
large, it doesn't depend
on how large M is.
It stays the same.
It becomes independent of n.
It doesn't depend on
where you started.
No matter where you start
in a finite-state
ergodic Markov chain.
After a very long time, the
probability of being in a
state j is independent of where
you started, and it's
independent of how long
you've been running.
So that's a very strong
kind of--
it's a very strong kind
of limit theorem.
It's very much like the law of
large numbers and all of these
other things.
I'm going to talk a little bit
at the end about what that
relationship really is.
Except what it says is, after a
long time, you're in steady
state, which is why
it's called the
steady state theorem.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you define the
steady states for periodic
changes [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I try to avoid doing
that because you have
steady state probabilities.
The steady state probabilities
that you have are, you take--
is if you have these
sub-classes.
Then you wind up with a steady
state within each sub-class.
If you assign a probability
of the probability in the
sub-class, divided by d, then
you get what is the steady
state probability.
If you start out in that steady
state, then you're in
each sub-class with probability
1 over d.
And you shift to the next
sub-class and you're still in
steady state, because you have
a probability, 1 over d, of
being in each of those
sub-classes to start with.
You shift and you're still in
one of the sub-classes with
probability 1 over d.
So there still is a steady
state in that sense, but
there's not a steady state
in any nice sense.
So anyway, that's
the way it is.
But you see, if you understand
this theorem for ergodic
finite state and Markov
chains, and then you
understand about periodic
change and this set of
sub-classes, you can
see within each
sub-class, if you look at--
if you look at--
if you look at time 0, time d,
time 2d, times 3d and 4d, then
whatever state you start in,
you're going to be in the same
class after d steps, the same
class after 2d steps.
You're going to have
a transition
matrix over d steps.
And this theorem still applies
to these sub-classes over
periods of d.
So the hard part of it
is proving this.
After you prove this, then you
see that the same thing
happens over each sub-class
after that.
That's a pretty major theorem.
It's difficult to prove.
A sub-step is to show that for
an ergodic M state Markov
chain, the probability of being
in state j at time n,
given that you're in state i at
time 0, is positive for all
i j, and all n greater than
M minus 1 squared plus 1.
It's very surprising that you
have to go this many states--
this many steps before you get
to the point that all these
transition probabilities
are positive.
You look at this particular kind
of Markov chain in the
homework, and I hope what you
found out from it was that if
you start, say, in state two,
then at the next time, you
have to be in 3.
Next time, you have to be in
4, you have to be in 5, you
have to be in 6.
In other words, the size of
the set that you can be in
after one step is just 1.
One possible state here, one
possible state here, one
possible state here.
The next step, you're in either
1 or 2, and as you
travel around, the size of the
set of states you can be in at
these different steps, is 2,
until you get all the way
around again.
And then there's
a way to get--
when you get to state 6 again,
the set of states enlarges.
So finally you get up to a
set of states, which is
up to M minus 1.
And that's why you get the M
minus 1 squared here, plus 1.
And this is the only Markov
chain there is.
You can have as many
states going around
here as you want to.
But you have to have this
structure at the end, where
there's one special state and
one way of circumventing it,
which means there's one cycle
of size M minus 1, and one
cycle of size M. And that's the
only way you can get it.
And that's the only Markov chain
that meets this bound
with equality.
In all other cases, you get this
property much earlier.
And often, you get it after just
a linear amount of time.
The other part of this major
theorem that you reach steady
state says, let P be
greater than 0.
In other words, let
all the transition
probabilities be positive.
And then define some quantity
alpha as a minimum of the
transition probabilities.
And then the theorem says, for
all states j and all n greater
than or equal to 1, the maximum
over the initial
states minus the minimum over
the initial states of P sub i
j to the n plus-- first step,
that difference is less than
or equal to the difference
a the n-th step,
times 1 minus 2 alpha.
Now 1 minus 2 alpha is
as a positive number.
And this says that this maximum
minus minimum is 1
minus 2 alpha to the n, which
says that the limit of the
maximizing term is equal
to the limit of
the minimizing term.
And what does that say?
It says that everything in the
middle gets squeezed together.
And it says exactly what we want
it to say, that the limit
of P sub l j to the n is
independent of l, after n gets
very large.
Because the maximum and
the minimum get very
close to each other.
We also showed that [? our ?]
approaches that limit
exponentially.
That's what this says.
The exponent here is just this
alpha, determined in that way.
And the theorem for ergodic
Markov chains then follows by
just looking at successive h
steps in the Markov chain when
h is large enough so that all
these transition probabilities
are positive.
So you go out far enough
that all the transition
probabilities are positive.
And then you look at repetitions
of that, and apply
this theorem.
And suddenly you have this
general theorem,
which is what we wanted.
An ergodic unichain is a Markov
up chain with one
ergodic recurring class,
plus perhaps a set
of transient states.
And most of the things we talk
about in this course are for
unichains, usually ergodic
unichains, because if you have
multiple recurrent classes,
it just makes a mess.
You wind up in this recurrent
class, or
this recurrent class.
And aside from the question of
which one you get to, you
don't much care about it.
And the theorem here is for an
ergodic finite-state unichain.
The limit of P sub i j to the
n probability of being in
state j at time n, given that
you're in state i at time 0,
is equal to pi sub j.
In other words, this limit
here exists for all i j.
And the limit is independent
of i.
And it's independent of n
as n gets big enough.
And then also, we can choose
this so that this set of
probabilities here satisfies
this, what's called the steady
state condition, the sum
of pi i times P sub i j
is equal to pi j.
In other words, if you start out
in steady state, and you
look at the probabilities of
being in the different states
at the next time unit, this is
the probability of being in
state j at time n plus 1, if
this is the probability of
being in state i at time n.
So that condition
gets satisfied.
That condition is satisfied.
You just stay in steady
state forever.
And pi i has to be positive for
a recurrent i, and pi i is
equal to 0 otherwise.
So this is just a
generalization
of the ergodic theorem.
And this is not what people
refer to as the ergodic
theorem, which is a much more
general theorem than this.
This is the ergodic theorem for
the case of finite state
Markov chains.
You can restate this in matrix
form as the limit of the
matrix P to the n-th power.
What I didn't mention here and
what I probably didn't mention
enough in the notes is
that P sub i j--
but also, if you take the matrix
P times P time P, n
times, namely, you take the
matrix, P to the n.
This says the P sub i j
is the i j element.
I'm sure all of you know that
by now, because you've been
using it all the time.
And what this says here--
what we've said before is that
every row of this matrix, P to
the n, is the same.
Every row is equal to pi.
P to the n tends to a matrix
which is pi 1, pi 2,
up to pi sub n.
Pi 1, pi 2, up to pi sub n.
And the easiest way to express
this is the vector e times pi,
where e is transposed.
In other words, if you take a
column matrix, column 1, 1, 1,
1, 1, and you multiply this by
a row vector, pi 1 times pi
sub n, what you get is, for this
first row multiplied by
this, this gives you--
well, in fact, if you
multiply this out,
this is what you get.
And if you've never gone through
the trouble of seeing
that this multiplication leads
to this, please do it, because
it's important to notice
that correspondence.
We got specific results by
looking at the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of stochastic
matrices.
And a stochastic matrix is the
matrix of a Markov chain.
So some of these things
are sort of obvious.
Lambda is an eigenvalue of P, if
and only if P minus lambda
i is singular.
This set of relationships
is not obvious.
This is obvious linear
algebra.
This is something that when
you study eigenvalues and
eigenvectors in linear algebra,
you recognize that
this is a summary of
a lot of things.
If and only if this determinant
is equal to 0,
which is true if and only if
there's some vector nu for
which P times nu equals lambda
times nu for nu unequal to 0.
And if and only if pi P equals
lambda pi for some
pi unequal to 0.
In other words, if this
determinant is equal to 0, it
means that the matrix P minus
lambda i is singular.
If the matrix is singular, there
has to be some solution
to this equation here.
There has to be some
solution to this
left eigenvector equation.
Now, once you see this, you
notice that e is always a
right eigenvector of P. Every
stochastic matrix in the world
has the property that e is a
right eigenvector of it.
Why is that?
Because all of the rows of a
stochastic matrix sum to 1.
If you start off in state i, the
sum of the possible states
you can be at in the next
step is equal to 1.
You have to go somewhere.
So e is always a right
eigenvector of P with
eigenvalue 1.
Since e is also is a right
eigenvector of P with
eigenvalue 1, we go up here.
We look at these if and
only if statements.
We see, then, P must
be singular.
And then pi times P
equals lambda pi.
So no matter how many recurrent
classes we have, no
matter what periodicity we have
in each of them, there's
always a solution to pi
times P equals pi.
There's always at least one
steady state vector.
This determinant has an M-th
degree polynomial in lambda.
M-th degree polynomials
have M roots.
They aren't necessarily
distinct.
The multiplicity of an
eigenvalue is the number roots
of that value.
And the multiplicity
of lambda equals 1.
How many different roots
are there which have
lambda equals 1?
Well it turns out to be just
the number of recurrent
classes that you have.
If you have a bunch of recurrent
classes, within each
recurring class, there's a
solution to pi P equals pi,
which is non-zero only one
that recurrent class.
Namely, you take this huge
Markov chain and you say, I
don't care about any
of this except this
one recurrent class.
If we look at this one recurrent
class, and solve for
the steady state probability in
that one recurrent class,
then we get an eigenvector
which is non-zero on that
class, 0 everywhere else, that
has an eigenvalue 1.
And for every other recurrent
class, we
get the same situation.
So the multiplicity of lambda
equals 1 is equal to the
number of recurrent classes.
If you didn't get that proof
on the fly, it gets
proved in the notes.
And if you don't get the proof,
just remember that
that's the way it is.
For the special case where all
M eigenvalues are distinct,
the right eigenvectors are
linearly independent.
You remember that proof we went
through that all of the
left eigenvectors and all the
right eigenvectors are all
orthonormal to each other,
or you can make them all
orthonormal to each other?
That says that if the right
eigenvectors are linearly
independent, you can represent
them as the columns of an
invertible matrix U.
Then P times U is
equal to U times lambda.
What does this equations say?
You split it up into a
bunch of equations.
P times U and we look at it as
nu 1, nu 2, nu sub [? n ?].
I guess better put the
superscripts on it.
If I take the matrix U and just
view it as M different
columns, then what this
is saying is that
this is equal to--
nu 1, nu 2, nu M, times lambda
1, lambda 2, up to lambda M.
Now you multiply this out,
and what do you get?
You get nu 1 times lambda 1.
You get a nu 2 times lambda 2
for the second column, nu M
times lambda M for the last
column, and here you get P
times nu 1 is equal to a nu 1
times lambda 1, and so forth.
So all this vector equation says
is the same thing that
these n M individual eigenvector
equations say.
It's just a more compact way
of saying the same thing.
And if these eigenvectors span
this space, then this set of
eigenvectors are linearly
independent of each other.
And when you look at the set of
them, this matrix here has
to have an inverse.
So you can also express this
as P equals this vector--
this matrix of right
eigenvectors times the
diagonal matrix lambda, times
the inverse of this matrix.
Matrix U to the minus 1 turns
out to have rows equal to the
left eigenvectors.
That's because these
eigenvectors--
that's because the right
eigenvectors and the left
eigenvectors are orthogonal
to each other.
When we then split up this
matrix into a sum of M
different matrices, each matrix
having only one--
and so forth.
Then what you get--
here's this--
this nice equation here, which
says that if all the
eigenvalues are distinct, then
you can always represent a
stochastic matrix as the sum of
lambda i times nu to the i
times pi to the i.
More importantly, if you take
this equation here and look at
P to the n, P to the n is U
times lambda times U to the
minus 1, times U times lambda
times U to the minus 1, blah,
blah, blah forever.
Each U to the minus 1 cancels
out with the following U. And
you wind up with P to the n
equals U times lambda to the
n, U to the minus 1.
Which says that P to the
n is just a sum here.
It's the sum of the eigenvalues
to the n-th power
times these pairs of
eigenvectors here.
So this is a general
decomposition for P to the n.
What we're interested in is what
happens as n gets large.
If we have a unit chain, we
already know what happens as n
gets large.
We know that as n gets large,
we wind up with just 1 times
this eigenvector e times
this eigenvector pi.
Which says that all of the other
eigenvalues have to go
to 0, which says that the
magnitude of these other
eigenvalues are less than 1.
So they're all going away.
So the facts here are that all
eigenvalues lambda have to
satisfy the magnitude
of lambda is less
than or equal to 1.
That's what I just argued.
For each recurrent class C,
there's one lambda equals 1,
with a left side and vector
equals the steady state on
that recurrent class
and 0 elsewhere.
The right eigenvector nu
satisfies the limit as n goes
to infinity.
So the probability that x sub n
is in this recurring class,
given that x sub 0 is equal
to 0, is equal to the i-th
component of that right
eigenvector.
In other words, if you have a
Markov chain which has several
recurrent classes, and you
want to find out what the
probability is, starting in the
transient state, of going
to one of those classes, this is
what tells you that answer.
This says that the probability
that you go to a particular
recurrent class C, given that
you start off in a particular
transient state i, is whatever
that right eigenvector
turns out to be.
And you can solve that right
eigenvector problem just as an
M by M set of linear
equations.
So you can find the
probabilities of going through
each transient state just by
solving that set of linear
equations and finding those
eigenvector equations.
For each recurrent periodic
class of period d, there are d
eigenvalues equally spaced
on the unit circle.
There are no other eigenvalues
with lambda equals 1-- with a
magnitude of lambda equals 1.
In other words, for each
recurrent class, you get one
eigenvalue that's equal to 1.
If that recurrent class is
periodic, you get a bunch of
other eigenvalues put around
the unit circle.
And those are all the
eigenvalues there are.
Oh my God.
It's--
I thought I was talking
quickly.
But anyway, if the eigenvectors
don't span the
space, then P to the n is equal
to U times this Jordan
reform, U to the minus 1, where
J is a Jordan form.
What you saw in the homework
when you looked at the--
when you looked at the
Markov chain--
OK.
This is one recurrent class
with this one node in it.
These two nodes are
both transient.
If you look at how long it takes
to get from here over to
there, those transition
probabilities do not
correspond to this
equation here.
Instead, P sub 1 2--
P sub 2 3, the way I've
drawn it here.
P sub 1 3 is n times this
eigenvalue, which
is 1/2 in this case.
And it doesn't correspond to
this, which is why you need a
Jordan form.
I said that Jordan forms
are excessively ugly.
Jordan forms are really very
classy and nice ways of
dealing with a problem
which is very ugly.
So don't blame Jordan.
Jordan simplified
things for us.
So that's roughly as far as we
went with Markov chains.
Renewal processes, we don't have
to review them because
you're already immediately
familiar with them.
I will do one thing next time
with renewal classes and
Markov chains, which is to
explain to you why the
expected amount of time to get
from one state back to itself
is equal to 1 over pi--
1 over pi sub i.
You did that in the homework.
And it was an awful
way to do it.
And there's a nice
I'll talk about that next time.